so let me explain something here about
uh michelob ultra we know how to drink
ernie
to remind players that even in the grind
it's only worth it if you enjoy it
uh michelob ultra celebrating the return
of the game with custom mini fridges
that inspired us to take part in the uh
inside the nba
basketball beer bounce challenge so
those were provided for uh
for players down there oh they're giving
them in the bubble they've given the
refrigerator and for a chance to win a
fridge
of your own follow at nickelo ultra on
twitter
or the truck right now yeah um
so anyway this this basketball beer
bounce
challenge that's what that's what you
guys are going to compete in
me and shaq yeah and how do you do that
you i'm glad you asked
here it is
oh wow oh this is going this is good oh
heck no no way yeah piece of cake
look at that you just got to catch it
yeah drop it
just catch it catch it no brother yeah
you don't have to worry about drinking
it just drop it and catch it
i've seen this this girl is good at this
that girl just wasted some damn beer
kenny shackled it was a restaurant
[Laughter]
this girl wastes a lot of beer he was
driving with himself
so are you up for that i'm up all right
all right all right
back to your spots it's gonna be yeah
it's gonna be amen socially distant
you know it's gonna be it's gonna be a
mess
i'm glad we're not using bottles yeah
that's for sure i'm glad we're not using
bombs so what
what you gonna do in a row no you just
gotta drop the ball
open it no but you got tin cans sir well
it's i don't know how many
call it i don't know how many it's going
to be because you're going to we're
going to put 45 seconds on the clock
and see who who uh catches the most you
got to open the beer
you got to open it you can't open these
you got to open each one
are you trying to get me locked up oh
yeah i'm gonna be like you sir you smell
like beer i haven't been drinking
officer i have not been
all right so where's the 45 seconds on
the clock
oh there it is on the screen ready are
you guys ready yeah go
oh oh my goodness try another one oh
this is such a clown
come on hey you got to catch it all
right come on man then y'all play in the
nba
you used to oh there you go hey there's
one
one for sure oh my god
jack's got the lead one nothing we got
23 seconds left come on chuck straight
good he's not gonna get one
nope come on
yo this uh studio smells like a big
nightclub
it counts you got three
you got three points
did you see anybody did you see the last
one truck crying
oh
please can we please see a replayer you
watch this one on
chucks
[Laughter]
studio right now oh my goodness oh man
all i need is some wings right now mr
officers i may smell like beer but i was
not drinking anything
nice play right there shaq oh yeah and
pants falling
oh well you talking about me see y'all
in 12 hours
yeah you're just about right on that one
now can we do that tomorrow double
header tomorrow